a quiet place at a chilling but riveting
film that delivers a fresh twist on the
horror genre you pick a movie lovers
it's Jan here and today I'm breaking
down the ending to a quiet place Plus
explaining some details you probably
didn't know about the creatures in the
movie if this is your first time here I
do regular movie breakdown so if you
enjoyed this video be sure to subscribe
for more spoiler warning I'll be
discussing the whole movie so take care
if you've not seen it yet a quiet place
is set in a near future in which an
alien invasion has decimated Suede's of
the human population around the world
the creatures have super-sensitive
hearing and so survivors like the
abbot's live as quietly as possible this
is why John Krasinski's character Lee
puts down sand trails to muffle sounds
while walking and everyday life has been
completely adapted to dampen any sound
the monsters are blind so visual signals
are an important way for the human
characters to communicate and because
the family have a deaf daughter they've
been able to use the American Sign
Language they learned with her to talk
silently with each other okay let's take
a look at the alien creatures and why
they attack and I think making a sound
design wise the aliens of rather
interesting the different from but do
bring to mind are the creatures like the
demo Gorgon and stranger things the
xenomorph in the alien movies the
monster in Cloverfield and the crazy
sharp teeth you see with venom the
film's production designer Jeffrey B
Kraft has said that he took inspiration
of the aliens formed from a nautilus
shell the Nautilus is a type of sea
creature that has very poor eyesight
although a quiet place dials that up
making the aliens completely blind by
the way there are various newspaper
clippings which describe the aliens as
either Angels of Death or death angels
which is interesting because in the
Jewish tradition the ark angel Samael is
known as the angel of death and is
sometimes referred to as a blind God as
well and the aliens really do seem to be
the bringers of death but Lee has been
researching them extensively and on his
whiteboard we can see the main things he
knows about them one thing he's still
trying to figure out is the answer to
the question why don't they and I think
that says eat their kill although the
movie doesn't seem to touch on this in
an obvious manner production designer
Jeffrey B Croft has explained that when
loud sound
vibrates within the aliens body it's
intensely painful and they will destroy
anything that makes noise and we do see
them pulsating and thrashing around when
they're faced with a big sound which
means the real reason why the creatures
attack anything making a loud noise
isn't the sport or for food instead it
seems like they're trying to eliminate
loud sounds in the environment around
them and of course as the family
eventually discovers although the aliens
hypersensitivity to sound makes them
deadly to life on earth it's actually
their weakness as well and that makes
them these efforts to develop a working
hearing aid for his daughter Regan
played by Millicent Simmons the key to
the story the new hearing aid he gives
that doesn't work properly and creates a
high-pitched sound that is not only
uncomfortable to her but is also an
barrel to the creatures when they're
nearby it seems likely that because the
aliens are blind they rely on a sort of
echolocation or bio sonar to emit sound
waves that they can track to navigate
and hunt these sound waves create audio
feedback when they hit the amplifiers in
Regan's hearing aid and because of the
creatures audio hypersensitivity the
amplified feedback sound ends up being
extremely painful for the aliens now
when you watch the movie you may have
been hoping that Regan knew this when
she and her brother were hiding in the
car as it could have saved their father
but at that moment she didn't understand
that the hearing aids audio feedback was
affecting the aliens when it happened
earlier the alien was behind her in the
cornfield and although we could hear the
creature rustling because Regan is deaf
she had no idea as behind her and when
Regan and her brother were in the silo
although she also felt the feedback she
didn't realize that was the reason the
creature ran off
it's not until Regan is in the basement
with her mother and they're confronted
with an alien that suddenly goes into an
uncontrollable spasm that Regan
understands her hearing aid has
uncovered the monsters weakness but the
feedback doesn't kill the creature and
it comes back at them however its head
is exposed as it opens up so Evelyn
kills it with a shotgun blast to the
face this leads us to the very final
moment of the movie where Evelyn and
Regan realize what they have to do as
the remaining aliens come running to the
farmhouse
- by the noise of the gun Regan and
Evelyn have the hearing aid speaker and
shotgun at the ready
according to Leigh's whiteboard there
should be two creatures left in the area
so it should be possible for them to
take both of them out the wider world
might also recover if the discovery can
be relayed to others so that sound based
weapons can be developed to take down
the alien invasion by the way the idea
of being pregnant during this
apocalyptic time is interesting both in
terms of the plot and for what it
symbolizes obviously it creates a huge
problem as not only as giving birth in
total silence impossible but a newborn
baby will also naturally cry out to cope
with this the family builds a special
basement area with a box for the baby
complete with an oxygen tank the
underground room is covered with a
mattress which seems to muffle sounds
coming from below enough to keep any
creatures from detecting them the birth
was actually supposed to take place in
this room but of course Evelyn was
forced to give birth in the bathroom
while she was hiding from the alien
invading the house symbolically Evelyn's
pregnancy and birth signals hope for
their family in the future of the world
and you can also see this in the fact
that despite their terrible situation
Evelyn tries to move forward by
homeschooling her children and both
parents try to maintain their spirits
with family dinners and board games this
indicates that the Abbott family is
trying to thrive not just survive during
this nightmarish time by the way the
scene where Evelyn is in the flooded
basement with the baby is an interesting
call back to earlier in the film where
Lee showed his son Marcos how the sound
the waterfall would mask noises they
made the sound of the water in the
flooding basement muffled some of the
sounds of the whimpering baby but Evelyn
took herself and the baby behind a sheet
of falling water as the baby started to
cry and just like the waterfall the
noise of the falling water was enough to
drown out the baby's crying so did you
enjoy a quiet place and what did you
think about the creatures also would you
like to see follow-up stories set in
this universe along the lines of say the
Cloverfield movies let me know your
thoughts in the comments below and you
can also tweet me at Jan underscore
Gilbert or at Flik city if you enjoyed
this I really appreciate you hitting
that like button and share
in the video plus you can check out more
of my breakdowns and horror movie videos
by tapping the screen right here thanks
for watching and see you next time you
PK movie lovers